[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we have we got sherry back we got david
back and we got geo back too
oh yeah this is honestly
the perfect lineup it is isn't it feels
good right representation all around the
[ __ ] shout out to jaleel white and
purple swipe up to be 85 years old
no i i'm really sore right now because
i've been personal training what oh
really i thought about hitting you all
up but y'all are so busy no don't hit me
up i've got time for you
ah that was fast i literally
i was doing that metal sled thing oh
that [ __ ]
kills your ass i was like shaking wait
what is it what does it do so it's a
sled and you push it and it really works
on your posterior chain
so people that want to build a booty
it's one of the best things you can do
oh really
hamstrings calves everything brush is it
is your ass or
let me tell you how it kind of it's so
[ __ ] effective everybody hates it so
much at the gym i go to nobody touches
no one touches really that's how [ __ ]
[ __ ] the squat rack was a [ __ ] line
yeah exactly this thing nobody touched
the same thing with battle ropes like
nobody ever does battle it's the worst
i've never done the ropes ropes are
[ __ ] up and then chinese jump bro
what the [ __ ] is the chinese jumbo wait
you guys are not in the gym were you
trying to trip someone haha
hello i tricked you
for play yeah the play play the the
string is around
two people's ankles yeah so it creates
this like huge
oval yeah i played that [ __ ] and then uh
you do tricks they do [ __ ] crazy how
high did you go up
so then it'll go up to the neck yes i've
seen that what the [ __ ]
how high did you go a lot um i never
went that high i'm not a jumper
but how high did you grow i'm a crawler
so you got to jump all the way in
and all the way out and but yeah all the
way in all the way out and then on top
of it
and then people do trace and [ __ ] i like
how asian people take a regular sport
and make it more difficult
why why the [ __ ] did it have to be like
that like what the [ __ ] so you put
ropes around your ankles and then you
just like it's like an elastic rope
yeah remember that thing where we had
the rope around our fingers and we do
that thing yeah yeah yeah
chinese jump rope no that's a chinese
finger trap this is a chinese finger
[ __ ]
that chinese finger [ __ ] yes inside this
way have a good time
wait is that what was that chinese can
you do korean accent oh all the time
actually you know who does a better
korean accent these two [ __ ] dude i
actually found out about these
guys before i met them because at a
thanksgiving my cousin
showed me a video of these guys doing a
video called korean history channel
and so i watched this video and i was
like what the [ __ ] are these guys this
is like nobody knew how to do a korean
accent until these people started doing
it publicly in videos
so i went to i didn't go to davis but i
visited my friends in davis and out of
nowhere
they started doing a korean accent and
i'm like how the [ __ ] do you know how to
make fun of my people
right and it was their video it was
going by wow i thought we were safe
yeah so everybody from that video
started imitating korean people because
nobody knew how to do it
wow same i couldn't crack it for a long
time
can you do it is this problem oh no i
got it nailed because you know like with
eight like axes there's always a
specific moniker that somebody would
follow
right and they cracked the code so
when when you figure out how to do a
korean accent we tend to drag our words
out very long towards the end
right and then they out they they kept
imitating what he would say it's not
even korean words
what would he say i got a [ __ ] in a can
every time i would walk somewhere
i'm like yo [ __ ] this guy dude but that
was
they do the best that's so funny wait do
it happy birthday
yeah there you go that's korean
see i'm not good at korean i've never
really attempted but vietnamese that's
my jam
because i grew up with vietnamese folks
and like like my my
two uh like for life best friends are
vietnamese so i was always around their
families so vietnamese is my jam but
that's not problematic right we talked
about it you if you're in the asian
community you can do other asian accents
i just give off
the [ __ ] i don't give up west l.a
talking again if you do it accurately
that's all that matters i think that's
what matters yeah
because i saw this one video just make
the joke uh white guy was vlogging
and and he was um he grew up in
singapore or something no
no that was a different one it was a
character yeah
his name was takashi something right and
he was full-on japanese and i couldn't
tell
if this dude grew up in japan and he was
just a japanese person
yeah but he looked white or it was like
a it was a character
and then later found out it's a
character it was like that uh that
awkward girlfriend character
he was a vlogger that had a japanese
accent but he killed it yeah
it was good and i thought it was
hilarious it depends because i saw this
mexican dude doing a trump impression i
was like
you can't do this man no no no no
no no i think it's just you know i think
comedy's so weird right if it makes
you laugh and it wasn't intended to be
offensive then i could laugh at it
some people don't like laughing anymore
no like dave chappelle on his stand up
said he went you know hi i'm chinese
like that should crack me he does have
an asian wife
yeah but a lot of people got mad at him
for that now i also think he gets a pass
i think dave should be like gets a pass
wait that's that's an older one right no
that's not the most recent netflix one
yeah but the joke wasn't about asian
people though it was it was it was
wrapped in some other stuff so it's like
but he did an
impression yeah and it was a bad one too
but he's the goat and also
if you're just too dumb to understand
what he's really making fun of that's
your back right i think chappelle is one
of those people that has like
earned the right to just oh he doesn't
feel that way he
he talks about however people hate on
him hard yeah so it's not like
just because we see it that way i
promise you he's getting hate for sure
dude i'm pretty sure he's getting death
threats emails whatever yeah he's wiping
his eyes with all the money he's making
exactly i get the same thing but i have
no money
would you rather be rich and hated or
poor and loved
i'd rather be rich and hated i read the
rich and loved dude what the [ __ ] why
are these things
you gotta choose you gotta choose you
can buy love actually
you really can't will smith can what do
we mean by poor though it depends on
who's hating me
think about escobar dude that whole
community loved him and he was rich as
[ __ ] yeah because he used to give them
so much money and all kinds of cool
benefits and [ __ ]
but what do you mean by poor they're
like how poor like flies on my face for
yeah like yeah flies in my eyeballs
trying to take a swim and [ __ ]
yeah you're so poor you can't get the
flies out of your eyes
no i just like normal normal not rich
normal not rich
oh like normal not rich a little below i
am that now okay okay let me okay is it
like this i walk into
uh [ __ ] uh olive garden right am i
looking at the
the numbers on the menu or am i just
ordering whatever i want oh [ __ ] you're
looking at the numbers do i sit down
get a water steal breadsticks and then
that's that's high school i think that's
have you done
hometown buffet did you get the
unlimited salad and breadsticks and
pretend like you went a feast
like oh no i haven't decided yet yeah
and then you walk up and say i ate this
restaurant oh my god that's so funny
dude the best [ __ ] is going into an
olive garden and then asking the waiter
like what do you recommend and they're
like
don't ask me gross questions oliver
oliveguard what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
ravioli a piece of [ __ ] yeah if i was a
waiter i would like pretend like i love
everything
yeah because you're good because
sometimes they're like well i actually
haven't tried that but i'm like
lie to me you know what's interesting i
want to be poor and hated like your
perception
like perception of food is so different
because when i was younger and i ate all
i thought it tasted amazing
and then i just ate regular food and i
was like yo this [ __ ] is terrible
remember bart's favorite high school
dish at that cafe the [ __ ] ham and
macaroni and [ __ ]
vomit on rice my goodness banana bay is
everything
it still exists banana base still exists
i think so they opened one in temple
city but i don't think it was as good
but banana bay coconut bait like the
drinks too and like
thai tea is good the whole yes plaza i
was addicted to creating machines have
we talked about this i've never been
there
wait have we never talked about this no
it's crazy i have an addiction to those
like cute uh oh crane machines all the
claws claw machines i'm sorry
yeah claw machines with the with the
hello kitties and stuff literally i
would spend
all my money i had a gambling addiction
truly like i would spend money he's like
gambling
savings which was only like a hundred
dollars back in 2009
like i would spend a hundred dollars and
get nothing like i needed to do it i
needed to
you never know what wait what's the high
from it though i don't know just a
gamble i don't [ __ ] know you like
watching kiropi falling out applause
it's also so cute it's also so cute um
maybe i just love animals
from the moment it's going down right
well it's going down you're getting
like oh
[Laughter]
i legit did win a bunch so i need to
find pictures of like i had this whole
couch you know there's a trick they do
with it right
yeah you go to the backup machine you
unplug it replug it in you get a free
thing
is that right yeah really that's what i
used to do all the time
that's stealing david because that's not
stealing the first grab you always get
something
is it how it works no i don't know what
it is but those those i'm i'm not sure
how it is now with the newer machines
but the older ones you just had to
unplug the back and replug it in fast
and you get a free ship and then you
could just grab it
also just stick your hand in around the
back also just shatter the glass
and just like duffel bag yeah that's all
you have to really do you ever play that
one that was such [ __ ] where it's
like stacked the cubes
and you hit the button and it stopped oh
yeah but it always stops you hit the
button
it stops like two seconds later you're
like oh my god they do that [ __ ] on
purpose to [ __ ] anxiety
dave and busters i like the coin one you
could drop coins and it just keeps
pushing it oh that's fun
vegas they have ones where they have
gold bars and [ __ ] iphones and like
yeah have you ever seen somebody win
[ __ ] at the slots in vegas
yeah it's crazy that shit's loud they're
like oh my god
today's video is brought to you by hbo
max
i love my hbo max and one of my favorite
shows that i used to watch on there is
euphoria
and every time i see a trailer and i
also follow zendaya who's the star of it
every time i see it pop
up i'm like oh is it season two is it
season two what's the euphoria i don't
ever watched it if you had
a childhood where you experimented with
lots of pharmaceuticals i did that and
you were
wondering who the hell you were and
understanding and exploring your
identity
i think you'll love it oh it sounds like
my childhood yeah because it brought me
back to that place where it was like
late junior high
high school and you're just like what's
going on am i cool am i not cool that's
the cool kid and you just had this crazy
underworld life and they got all these
amazing actors and it tells a really
good story and the cinematography like
everything on hbo max
is cinematography is always on point
yeah
so i'm really excited for the season two
to come back and of course
i can't wait for the debut of suicide
squad
and space jam is gonna be on hbo max
when they come out on theaters it's
gonna come out on hbo max
at the same time so cool and it's only
available on the 14.99 a month
subscription but the cool thing is it's
an ad-free plan
but it's only going to be streaming for
a limited time so you
better not wait hbo max has everything
that you love
all in one place so stream all of your
favorites maybe find some new ones too
you can sign up at hbom.ax slash otr
august you can even download titles so
you can take it on the go with you
that's hbom.ax
otr august to check out hbo max
yeah but i i see that but then it's
always like they won forty one dollars
yeah you know saying like at the buffalo
gold like the five cent machine
this lady won 50k whoa it was like this
80 year old lady
it was just coins flying out yeah well
she didn't know what was going on
and so some other person i'd tell them
like you just want a lot of money just
wait right here
and somebody will come and help you
because she's just she's like i pooped
myself
[ __ ] sake where am i i was at the high
roller
um like i was poor as [ __ ] but i had i
had 100 bucks and i was like i just want
to play the high roller slots one time
walked in i was like that machine walked
up pulled 1200 bucks
cashed out and left holy [ __ ] just one
roll one roll
400 bucks for 100 yeah
wow cool man i'm going to vegas tomorrow
i'm excited what are you going to do
what are you doing over there it's
vanessa my my roommate slash soul sister
her 30th so we had to do it big um i'm a
little nervous about covid
but because we planned this like you
know a month and a half ago yeah
everyone has this so it's fine
it was euphoric um but we're doing
encore day club
bottle service the whole nine we had to
do big what are you working on
what do i wear to that so i will wear a
bathing suit
but uh maybe hat but i have this soju
like i dare you to wear that [ __ ] hat
in the water oh my god i would never
first of all there's already so much
[ __ ] that has splattered on here there's
like pamper mousse lacroix
oh [ __ ] um there's uh my neighbor's
tears
okay um there's a good start why was
your neighbor above you
honestly i have the best neighbors okay
i tried to seduce one recently and it
was like
how what is it yeah what does that look
like he's baby innocent
i think that's what the conclusion was
oh i wouldn't i don't know if it's
mutual yeah you're not afraid of getting
covered you're about to be on some big
projects i had a friend who who had the
shot
went to vegas got the delta period no so
that's the thing that's the thing so i
don't leave until september 5th so this
is my last risk
gosh yeah that has been planned for so
long i have to go i mean we're going
you if you catch it you're good you're
fine and stay home you're quarantined
for two weeks
yeah it's all the things like i just
need to we might catch cover on the
plane there so
who knows i'm driving i'm not that rich
don't go to vancouver oh vancouver
um yeah i'm just gonna double mask i'm
gonna [ __ ] wear
you know do what you gotta do scheme
pantyhose pantyhose over my face but
with this [ __ ] scorpion mask on
youtube
the bane masks yeah albany ones would be
maybe i should get that
filtration oh my god i actually hate
flying so much i think have i talked
about motion sickness
nope so um growing up here and like
being born in shanghai like just we went
back and forth all the time when i was
little like i mean that's like 12 hours
and like
i would just always throw up and i feel
so emotional so i'm like conditioned
to hate planes like even like the
thought of a plane the thought of an
airport like can you be on a boat
it's pretty rough you get um
do you get carsick driving yourself no
if they take ways if they lose weight i
get the [ __ ] out of the car yeah because
i'm like you're going to take
yeah so i'm just like i hate flying it's
not the fear of flying i don't mind
heights or whatever
the [ __ ] um but you still throw up
though not
no i don't throw up on planes anymore
boats yes you don't take dramamine i
should ecstasy is good
it's a pretty simple solution here you
know what's funny there's this hold
on a second that's what everybody does
you've had motion six you know there's a
clear solution to this you go
i should probably do that yeah i'm a
masochist
they have non-drowsy dramamine too i oh
yeah okay i'll do it i'll do it okay
fine i've
been converted you don't like taking
pills
um i actually have never done sse not
just like
medicine like tylenol no stop forcing me
to take ecstasy
no i took a tylenol this morning um
because
hung over and also well i don't know
i've been like
randomly taking tylenol for fun if i'm
like
um not paranoid about covet but i'm just
like ah it'll it'll because it says
um fever reducer on the bottle so like
i'll randomly take it if i'm like i saw
a lot of people
it's like weird isn't tylenol super bad
for your liver if you think you don't do
it every day
i'm not every day i'm [ __ ] good and
reducing the symptom doesn't mean you're
reducing the illness you're just
reducing i don't know it's placebo but
okay i didn't know it's bad for your
liver because i also drink so much [ __ ]
my life spins your blood
that's how you get that's the worst
thing about is you you drink so much
that night before and then you take
tylenol the next day it's like it's like
a bad combination the double double
do some tai chi in the morning that'll
do you good okay
okay my grandma had this
um remedy for motion sick
you tape a piece of ginger to your belly
button okay and it's supposed to balance
you because that's really what it is you
use scotch tape or duct tape
is that why you threw up on planes for
years yeah is that how well it works
i'm allergic to ginger um she tapes a
piece i want to see you get patted down
at a [ __ ] airport and they just see
this [ __ ] ginger in your belly
i never did it clearly i don't do
anything like that what the [ __ ] is this
oh my god one time at tsa they found
something like ginger smuggler yeah
ginger smoke
one time at tsa they found something in
my butt like you know what
the machine like that thing that has
like the yellow spot
where there's something there what's in
your butt it was like a square on my
butt and i didn't know
so i had to they had to like do
something they had to bend you over
[ __ ]
clear your [ __ ] what was the square i
don't know maybe i just used the baby
wipe and maybe there's chemicals
in the baby wipe that was a square
perfect square
well no i wasn't i just taped the baby
wipe too much oh
that's what it was that these perfect
sets you use baby wipes in an
interesting way
well yeah because the booty gotta stay
clean
where are we on eating booty have we
talked about eating booty here yeah it's
wonderful i ate her booty before
it's wonderful oh one of the best joys
of life
what what do people do when they have
like those remote vibrators
that the couples you know like the
boyfriend holds the thingy it's a
vibrator
yeah and then they go into the airport
and they get caught with that
or a butt plug oh it's like the guy has
the remote and they control the vibrator
oh wow
just every like just right so they just
like order against starbucks and i get a
lot
they're all vibrating
karma hot that's hot that's a good word
for that though cause you're not gonna
say like can i get the eggs
better and then you'll be funny if like
the barista also like okay
it's like i guess that's how we stay
here
it's a bdsm convention yeah yeah right
right right right right right right
sponsored by
starbucks it's not that crazy or funny
it's not gonna happen it could really
happen
would you all do that that's pretty hot
i think i think the whole dominant
like obviously to a certain extent the
whole dominant submissive thing is
really hot
that's it that's stuff to say do you
like to be dominated or do you like to
be more submissive once again it all
depends on my mood you are just a
complicated human being you never have a
straight answer dude
no i haven't been straight for a long
time a cop would [ __ ] hate you you
just they're interrogating you like
depends what do you want from me yeah no
what about your chinese manchester i
hate your guts make up your mind man
my mom uh is so proud
but yeah the queer conversation is still
forever she literally doesn't care if
like who the hell gives me the sperm she
wants to be a grandma so bad
so bad i also have a friend korean girl
they know that she is gay right been gay
for the longest [ __ ] time but till
this day
they still ask her when she's gonna have
a kid and she's like i don't like men
and i don't want to be pregnant right
but their parents are still like kind of
hoping
and so like they met me one day she'll
change my mind and they're like he's
nice
and i'm like what do you mean i'm nice
they're like she wants to have a kid
i'm like wait what the [ __ ] oh my god
that's so funny really wanted
asian parents i think they have their
own agenda and everything just
goes over there so my dad's in denial
they're in denial like this whole time
my dad's been asking me because he
i think he wants to move to vegas he
could be closer to taika and
every time i meet up with him which is
almost every month or every two weeks
he's like so are you gonna stay there
for a long time
and i keep telling him i'm like honestly
i don't know i'm gonna stay there for a
year
feel it out and then i'll let you know
if i'm gonna stay like five or ten years
or whatever because right now i really
don't know we just got there we're in
the honeymoon phase everything seems
awesome but who knows
our feelings might change but every time
i meet him so are you gonna still stay
there forever
i wonder if that's because his age and
he forgets yeah i'm like i [ __ ] told
you i'll ask me in 2022 i'll let you
know
that's the thing it's like we get so
frustrated when our parents ask the same
questions but it's like
what if they just forget yeah and also
they just need that reassurance they
need verbal reassurance
my mom has been that way since they
[ __ ] won and she uses that excuse she
goes oh i'm so old i mean shut the [ __ ]
up you were like that 30 years ago what
are you talking about
ever since i was born you were like this
but now they're trying to use the old
people
oh for sure like no no that's funny well
my mom my mom knows that
i'm into both and like it could be a
husband or a wife type of thing
but still like you we need the sperm for
actual you know so when the time comes
and if i need like to do like
you know um sperm bank yeah then i'm
gonna that's what i was about to say
like you could be
my the version of me and then i could
use my beautiful wife's uh egg
that's perfect but my mom also wants me
to freeze my eggs like hey sap she's
like literally i need to do it too i
actually want to
oh no 31. oh you're fine who knows who
knows
do what you want to do no i do want to
freeze a lot of my friends uh
are that's the west valley fomo freeze
before you go to vancouver
no the recovery vancouver's in like two
seconds i'm leaving in a month can you
believe
i'm gonna miss you all but then three
months so you're gonna be back in like
2022.
when you never come again we'll we'll
remember you i hope i come again
soon hey nice hey nice thank you i can't
do that don't you give me something all
right give me some yeah
oh good job good job good job oh this is
very very uh moist honey you like that
where are we on the word moist like it
or love it i love it i love it me too
reminds me of who doesn't love that a
lot of people don't like it i'm like
what's wrong makes them feel weird what
about cervix
you guys like that word yeah oh i love
it i love a crunchy crunchy finish
i love pounding that works
oh do you guys say dick or [ __ ] or penis
in bed i see it all all of it
i don't say penis though i wouldn't say
that in bed do you want this penis
that's too magical would you like this
penis on a plaque
open wide
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you